hello hearties all over the world good
morning good afternoon good
evening it is so exciting to have you
joining us today
for a live event celebrating the season
eight
of when calls the heart you know me i'm
deidre behar with entertainment tonight
and i'm so excited to be joined by a few
of my favorite faces from hope valley
please help me welcome a few of the
stars of when calls the heart
erin cracow chris mcnally and kevin
mcgary hi you guys
hi deidra how's it going guys how you
feeling
pretty good yeah no complain
i'm very excited about season eight of
when calls the heart i have so many
burning questions that we will get to
in just a moment but kind of before we
start i you know i obviously want to
acknowledge that we're still virtual i
wish i could give you a hug in real life
but um you know we've had some fun
conversations over the last year
through the internet and i want to just
check in ask how you're doing
chris let's start with you how's the
vegetable garden going at home
uh it has not begun yet it's uh i'm
about to start doing some things
inside you know my tomatoes and whatnot
trying to learn from some mistakes i
made last year i made
i made several but i'm excited i think
this summer we're going to be
totally the goal is to not need to go to
the grocery store
that's the idea and i think we can
achieve it
all right farm to table in the mcnally
household they love that correct
aaron how are you doing are you still
working on that karaoke song
so um
working on the karaoke song this is a
great question um
no i short answer
i think i failed i
i am keeping an ear to the ground for
songs that
excite me but no i think i haven't
really found it yet
i haven't found the right song
what's what's the holdup cause you know
fans are
dying to get a little glimpse into
whatever it may be
i mean is it karaoke you're working on
are you baking brownies we got to see
you doing that last year what
i guess what have you been up to i don't
even know what i've been up to i stopped
with the baking because that was clearly
a disaster
although an entertaining one
uh well wait a minute that's not true
actually we baked a bit this season
didn't we
um we basically successful cinnamon buns
that's kind they were successful the
cinnamon buns it was a group effort
um the chocolate chip cookies were
subpar though
agreed we can do better
they were a little on the salty side
i like felt a little too much
this was my fault i think i did like
salted butter
plus i added in the salt plus we did
chris's signature like
uh sea salt flakes on top it was just it
was a lot of
salt uh can i ask was this like a cast
bonding activity like a great one calls
the heart
bacon um chris and i lived
very close together and so a few of us
got together uh together to
fake a few things yeah love that okay
we'll have to check back with you for
that recipe
maybe a little less bulbs but uh we
definitely want the cookie recipe
great uh and kevin what's going on with
you have you been
riding riding the motorcycle um
no it's like minus 20 degrees celsius
here
um i've been working on it a little bit
in the garage you know what i've been
doing
actually is um i've been purging a lot
of stuff i've been going through boxes
of things that i've just collected over
the years that
i don't need anymore and i'm just kind
of minimalizing
the clutter in my life that's what i'm
doing right now okay
what what were you uh going through was
it clothes old baseball cards
what was it oh just baggage
that's emotional just like
things that i've had you know yeah books
and and um
i don't know just old clothes trying to
give them away and stuff just things
that you know
i don't really need anymore so yeah it's
a good time to do that right now
yes of course um well i'm happy to see
that you're all happy and healthy and of
course here to celebrate
season eight of when calls the heart
which is premiering in just a few days
um kind of tell me what how you guys are
feeling right now and how excited you
are for this moment
it's been a long time since we've been
in hope valley and so
i i don't know i feel just as excited as
the hardys to get
to get back there and share these
stories with everyone it was really
it was such a bright spot to be able
to reconnect and reunite in hope valley
and
get back to work together i think it was
really needed
and appreciated and um so it'll be
really fun to get to share all that with
the viewers chris how are you feeling
i'm excited i'm excited because i this
happens every year where
we film we we shoot the whole season and
so i've we've all experienced it and
then
i forget about it and then several
months later we're like hey you ready to
start the season
we already did it so i i feel like i get
a second chance
to i get to relive it for a second time
um
alongside the hearties and and it's just
it's fun so and i usually
i find that i forgot what we shot so i'm
like oh yeah i'm
talking about that right so i get to
so i'm looking forward to it that that's
great you film it and then you kind of
get to almost relive it like us like as
a fan watching it
by week on tv kevin how are you feeling
about it
yeah i think the exact same as chris you
know you go in there and you spend so
much time kind of doing
focusing on you know your storyline and
and what you're
bringing to the show so it's fun to to
watch and kind of see this entire world
happen with all these characters that
you know i just it's not that i was
ignoring but just that i um
you can be honest kevin you know whoever
you know see all the other story lines
um and yeah and just kind of
i'm excited to see how the fans are
going to uh like season 8 because
there's some really great story lines in
it well i have a funny feeling that
they're going to be moved and it's going
to be heartwarming and it's going to
take us on a real roller coaster of an
adventure
before we get into it i kind of just
want to back up for a second
um of course the season seven finale
ended with
quite a heavy moment and and a
cliffhanger
um with elizabeth in nathan's arms when
we thought there was a possibility we
could have lost him there
um aaron can you share with us where
season eight is going to pick up
um shortly thereafter time in hope
valley is a bit of a fluid thing but
um i'd say a couple months maybe
and um the the thing about the time
that's passed though is that we
were telling the story as if elizabeth
and nathan
haven't really spent too much time
together within that time
he's been traveling um and the same
with lucas he went off out of town and
so
um though time has passed we really are
kind of getting the opportunity to pick
up right where we left off at least in
those
relationships between the characters so
it'll be exciting to see where things
pick up i mean i know where things pick
up but i think
everyone else will be excited to see it
uh kevin and chris can you share a
little bit about where
nathan and lucas's mindset is at you
know kind of in the aftermath of that
you know very traumatizing
experience at the end of season seven
um well i for nathan um i think
he's he's had his world kind of shook a
little bit and um
he's starting to put things more into
perspective of what he wants
and what he's willing to give up to to
go after the things that he wants
my turn i think so i thought you're
frozen
uh lucas takes some time away he leaves
hope valley to kind of
shift his perspective and um and
recalibrate
and then he once he's found that he
decides to come back and that's sort of
what we where we pick up
lucas re-entering pope valley um
and basically just wanting whatever's
best for elizabeth
whatever that might be and i i hope i
can speak on behalf of
of all hearties that that's truly what
we want at the end of the day we know
she's got two amazing
guys to choose from but we want
elizabeth to do what's best for her and
follow her heart
and aaron i i just want to quickly point
to a moment
um that we recently saw in the trailer
um that just dropped
very emotionally takes her wedding ring
off
and i would just love to know from you
um
what do you think that symbolizes was
that emotional for you to film that that
scene right there
it was something that we had been
talking about
for a long time actually finding the
right moment
to do something like that and and there
were moments where we thought
maybe we'd try and squeeze it in but it
really wasn't until
um well i'll just say toward the very
end of
this coming season that it felt like the
right moment to
make that move so um
it was emotional sure yeah it's a big
step for her
um and
and what was the other part of the
question i forgot what where's your
heart at right now because that's it
that's a big
step right well i think what it's
signifying is
is a more concrete display of
all right ready to move on ready to
fully embrace love and all that comes
with it um
without without the constant
visual reminder of of her past love
so i think it it just makes things a
little bit cleaner
well i i love that you use the word
cleaner but i have to
imagine that the back and forth between
lucas and nathan
as they try to earn the affection of
elizabeth i have to imagine that there's
going to be somewhat of a rollercoaster
ride
uh kevin let's start with you i'm
curious about
where nathan's uh mind is at right now
where's his heart at is he gonna be
um you know kind of respectfully
pursuing elizabeth like you know
sort of um a more laid-back approach
like we've seen in the past or do you
think he's gonna
uh sort of bump up the confidence and
kind of go after
her with a little more um kind of
directness
well i i know what he does i don't think
he he
um yeah i know he he does
bump it up and um and kind of start
putting like i said
put things into perspective what he
wants and um
and kind of fully goes for it um
you know you'll see in in in the first
couple episodes just what he's willing
to uh give up to get the things that he
wants
the things that he wants the well
maybe it's not just elizabeth he wants
some other things
not saying elizabeth is a thing oh no
i've gone down a path
elizabeth is the queen i think we all
agree elizabeth is a true queen
to get the queen that he wants
we know that we know that lucas is also
vying for
queen elizabeth um what is that
what what is lucas's approach this
season because we know that he's no
stranger to
really romantic grand gestures is that
going to continue in season eight
there's some
there are some romantic gestures i would
say yeah
um i mean i i don't i
personally don't classify them as as
these giant giant things it's more
a dinner and if you consider that to be
a big deal cool
if not great um
but yeah again i think lucas struggles
a little this oh actually i don't know i
can't give away any spoilers
um i'll just say i'll just say again
that he wants what's best for
elizabeth and there's a little bit of
is it the same as what lucas wants is it
not
i don't know but he wants her to be
happy
and that's very very fair um before we
kind of get into your
individual story lines you know outside
of of you know the suitors and elizabeth
um i'm just i'm just curious erin for
you
um what do you think is ultimately gonna
tip the scale
for elizabeth what what is it that she's
looking for
and what are the qualities in each
gentleman that you think really appeal
to her
well i think they're obviously the the
sort of checklist
items right she wants to find someone
who's going to be a great father figure
to her son
she wants to find someone who's going to
be um
supportive of her interests
someone who's kind and thoughtful and
funny and sensitive
and a good listener all those things
that you look for in a partner
definitely tall definitely brown hair um
would be nice if you could ride a horse
i don't know um
i think though that her journey through
this season
toward making that decision is just
about listening to her heart and her gut
and really
really listening to that voice within
and and
figuring out who is the person that's
going to be her
next and hopefully final great love
um as far as qualities in these two
gentlemen
that really stand out um
i think uh we're talking about
characters right because there's
many things that i admire about kevin
and chris
i could go on share those as well yes
please
um well one of the things that i think
elizabeth really appreciates about lucas
is that he seems to
really care deeply about her interests
and what inspires her
um so he's always uh
supporting and champion championing her
as a writer
um obviously you know she's passionate
about teaching but the writing is
is sort of like that secret dream and he
wants to help support that and so i
think that's a really
um loving quality
and as far as equality in nathan he is
incredibly protective
of elizabeth and um
and he's also someone who has
experienced
a similar kind of loss and so i think
these two people connect on a very deep
level um through through their shared
experiences
and um and it's just a
it's a it's a very beautiful connection
and i think there's a lot of love in
that as well
i gotta be honest i don't i don't envy
elizabeth she's got a very
tough choice between the two of them
it's it's tough
and i know that you guys have already
finished filming season eight
so i i want you to give me your best
poker face there's no spoilers here
i know i'm just curious
uh how you feel knowing that elizabeth
has made her decision
are you happy with her decision um and
how do you think the fans are going to
feel
best poker face best poker face
fine what is it you say in the states
i'd like to plead the fourth
the third the fifth
i like to plead before i don't know what
the fourth is what's the fourth one we
gotta find out what the horn is
what did
[Laughter]
as fans of the show yourself i hope
you're fans of the show
um what do you think about the final
decision and how do you think fans are
going to feel
well i will say it is
about time and i think that the fans
will
feel similarly they're just like let's
wrap up the triangles so we can get
started with the love story i think
they're ready and so i think they will
be very happy
that that we have a decision
that we have a decision this season um
you know look we have gone down the path
of
teams and so one of those teams is going
to be
probably disappointed um
but please know that
we have very uh
big plans for that team and
assuming we get a season nine that team
will find
uh great joy oh my gosh this is
impossible how am i supposed to answer
this question
no yeah i think
i think the whole thing is is handled
with a lot of care and class and as much
empathy as we could muster
and um and i just hope that the fans
continue to trust us as we navigate this
uh delicate journey together
and i know go for it i was just saying
you know
it's it's so nice to kind of like
there's it's no secret that there's
passionate fans
on believe it or not on either side
of you know on each team and
you know to be you know you read some of
the stuff you're like wow
but to to be part of something that is
giving entertainment and joy
uh right now especially is just it's
it's so
nice like you know and you know of
course like aaron said
you know the losing team if if we want
to look at winners or losers because you
know the story goes on
but the team who doesn't end up with
elizabeth
will essentially like you know we'll
move on there will be other stories
and you know as much as
it is who's going to end up with
elizabeth it is it's about
a group of people living together in
hope valley and yes
that's not going to go anywhere it is a
community and you know we get to see
two people kind of move forward in a
love uh in a love story but
there's another character and they're
like who knows what's gonna happen with
that person and they've got
endless possibilities of what's gonna
you know what can happen with the other
character and um
yeah it just it hope value will continue
and um i i think you know it will be a
blow
obviously um but
i think it's it's the best way to move
forward really what
if people start thinking about i think
it's the best way we're moving forward
with the story if this was if one calls
the heart was a show
all about elizabeth's journey to find
love
the show would have ended right after
season one
because it was clear she found love at
the end of season one
there's so much more to win calls the
heart than just
elizabeth's romance and the love
triangle
um and that's one of the really exciting
things about season eight actually our
new show runner john tinker has just
done an incredible job
exploring all the back stories of our
ensemble cast
getting to know everyone even better and
that's really saying something in an
eighth season you think you know these
people pretty well but
but we really get to know and understand
the the very fabric of pope valley in a
way that we haven't
in in seven seasons so it'll be really
exciting for people to get to
enjoy that i love hearing that because
like you just pointed out it is an
ensemble cast there are so many
other characters of course i'm very
invested in the three of your characters
but
i find myself you know laughing smiling
getting joy from
the group as a whole um i'm hoping that
you guys can share a little bit about
uh not only your own storylines and the
challenges that your
your characters are going to be facing
but aaron as an executive producer
i'd love if you could share a little bit
about what's going on with clara and
jesse what's going on with team
infirmary
lee rosemary
where to begin clara and jesse you would
think that we would go the
happy honeymooner newlywed path but no
actually
what they're getting to explore this
season is the challenges of becoming
newly married and it isn't all smooth
sailing
um and for team infirmary
they're kind of figuring out next steps
there are opportunities
outside of hope valley that might
pull them apart and so they're trying to
figure out what's the right move for
them are they in it for the long haul
or was it just a passionate hope valley
fling
between doctor and and and doctor
actually
um and then uh lee and rosemary
so a lot of their journey is about
trying to figure out
their passions in life what's going to
really fuel them what they want to do
you know
rosemary always thought she was going to
have a stage built and
and just continue on her path as an
actor but we find that
she goes in another direction um
so finding um finding direction
would be their theme i would say what
about team hickam
team hickam is very
involved in the oil
situation in hope valley and
we also discovered that he's got a bit
of a crush on
a lady in town so seeing how they
navigate that
is very sweet and
chaste and darling
and and as far as
elizabeth goes this was an interesting
season for me because
not to focus on it too much but because
of the pandemic we have to be really
extra careful with our little ones on
set so
i i couldn't really spend the same kind
of time in the
classroom with all of the students just
in that contained space it wasn't really
going to be safe so we had to limit the
school room scenes
and even the scenes with the little
jacks um
those were tricky and we had to limit
those as well so
um i ended up getting to play out a
really
um really interesting story with the new
canfield family who come to town where
elizabeth wants to bring
angela canfield into the classroom but
because
angela is blind her mother is very
protective of her
and so elizabeth is facing that
challenge of trying to figure out how to
convince
minnie to allow angela to join the
classroom
is that is that an emotional kind of
back and forth for elizabeth
yeah i think it's challenging and and
you know there's a really poignant scene
that i share with natasha who plays
minnie
angelo's mom where elizabeth is saying
like i i'll do this i'll do this and and
i understand i understand what you've
been through and
minnie kind of says you really don't you
really don't understand
and i think it's an incredibly important
lesson that
you can think you know what a person is
going through
but sometimes you should just sit back
and listen
and let them share their experience
before before proceeding as if you have
all of the answers
um so lots to
dig into there in that storyline well
said and i
i am truly so excited to meet the
canfield family i know that
they're going to be wonderful additions
to the town of hope valley
um chris i want to talk to you a little
bit about
lucas what's going on with with gowan
petroleum and the saloon
how's lucas feeling this season
well i'll say he's feeling pretty great
about
finally getting his own ride
i'm so happy
wait is that a spoiler can i say that
well i mean he has to get back
it's yeah you can say that i could see
the trailer
yeah i don't know i haven't i don't know
that i've seen it
but uh but great so yeah lucas lucas
gets
a very fine convertible and uh so that's
that's very that's great
i feel like we pleaded publicly for that
and it happened this season so
success makes sense cool guy needs a
cool car it does i don't
yeah i totally agree i i think one of
the wealthiest if not the wealthiest guy
in town shouldn't have to borrow a ride
he should just
go buy one um well stop buying libraries
man
buy yourself a car yeah
seven live so it's been up in the town
for some reason
well the library business is going great
uh the car business is great the oil
business
turns out to be a bit of a disaster and
i think at the end of season seven we
sense
that from lucas that he walks into the
office and he's like i i have no idea
what i'm doing
i've been way over my head um hickam
actually comes through in quite a strong
way for lucas he becomes a
sort of uh his right-hand man of
confidant and just a very savvy
knowledgeable
reliable source um but things
start to spiral out of control so i
think
[Music]
lucas finds himself in a position where
he doesn't feel like he can trust gow
and that
business relationship is completely
crumbled but
he's stretched so thin that
he's stuck between a rock and a hard
place does he try and go back to gowan
and say
i need help or does he try and power
through does he just abandon it
um yeah i think he's under a lot of a
lot of stress in the oil department
as well as the lady department wow
really does wear quite a few hats so uh
i'm hoping that things things go
smoothly as he juggles everything
um kevin let's talk a little bit about
mounty nathan
um obviously the season seven finale
cliffhanger was uh was emotional and a
lot
how is he feeling in season eight and
maybe talk a little bit about his
relationship with ali
yeah well like i said before you know he
he gets
what happened at the end of season seven
shakes him a little bit and
he refocuses his life for what he wants
um
that being said not only you know does
he pursue elizabeth
even stronger he starts he starts making
some you know big decisions
um without giving any spoilers he starts
making some big decisions what else he
wants in his life
and relationships that he wants to
really kind of secure and um
and strengthen and you know then
if it's not elizabeth i think the
biggest person that he cares about on
that show
is is ally of course so he really
strengthens that relationship
um throughout this season uh and another
one that he really does that i really
like playing is with bill
nathan and bill kind of have this great
like
dynamic together um and i did a lot of
work with jack this year and i really
liked
like i i really like this kind of
buddy cop thing they have going on where
there's you know there's been this type
of mutual respect
kind of eventually like ingrained in
both of them for each other
that they're both kind of on the same
side um
you know but they're but they're both
kind of a bit shmari to each other as
well um
and there were some really great scenes
i got to play with uh with jack like
really funny stuff i thought
um so yeah one of my favorite scenes
is is between you and jack i think it
was last season right where you're like
you're chopping wood of course it's one
of my favorite scenes and you're
it's like really windy and your hair is
all crazy and
jack comes over and starts to chop wood
with you it's just so great
yeah it's just such a nice scene where
he's clearly there to help out but like
it you know in a bro
way yeah who does bro better than jack
wagner
[Laughter]
hey bro um
but uh and we've got some great stuff
this year too you know that he's just
you know you bill really kind of looks
after nathan in a way and especially in
the fir
you know one of the episodes in the
first four episodes um
he really goes to bat for nathan um over
some pretty serious stuff
um yeah so it you know if
it's not elizabeth it's on nathan's mind
it's the other two big relationships
yeah yeah well just based off of those
teases alone i can already tell
season eight is is perhaps going to be
the best season yet
of when calls the hearts and i also i
want to congratulate
the three of you on um you know
elevating the season from not just
10 episodes but now we get 12.
i i know that the anticipation is going
to be building the entire way through
something that one calls the heart does
so magically is you always deliver a
really powerful and really moving
finale so without spoiling anything
i would love to see your faces your
expressions
when you read the season eight finale
script
what draft
[Laughter]
final draft what word
what was your reaction you just want us
to make faces
at you i'd love to see your face your
expression and then i
i'd love to know uh your reaction was it
surprising was it moving was it
jaw-dropping
[Laughter]
oh wow giving us range chris you look
stressed out
very stressed out and uh and kevin how
did you react when you read it
just a happy guy he was like oh yeah
[Laughter]
saw that saw that
um okay so to wrap that up then chris
was really stressed
kevin was kind of like happy but aloof
maybe and i
ran the gamut to be fair i didn't find
out until i showed up on the day to
shoot it i was like oh
okay what are you doing yeah
why don't i believe that yeah you should
just like to like do things in the
moment
you know i show up oh okay because this
guy doesn't read the scripts he doesn't
prep anything he just gets there just
somebody tell me what
rolls with it i'll get there yeah
but on a more serious note like what are
the emotions and and
what is the message that you hope the
hearties take away from from season
eight and
and the conclusion of this love triangle
that we've been so invested in
for now a couple seasons
who wants to go well i would say in
hope valley we always aim for everyone
to find happiness
that's the goal happiness so um
i think we can count on
hopefully everyone having a happily ever
after
um and i hope we get a season nine so we
can explore these
happily ever afters even more
how's that that was great kevin chris
anything you want to add there
yeah well i think that i think that part
of what john
tinker was trying to do in season eight
is create
environments or situations within all
the different
families or dynamics in hope valley the
couples in hope valley
that people authentically can relate to
and are familiar with in their own life
to some degree
so um i think i think he was trying to
bring the audience
in in that way and i feel like he
succeeded based on what
i read um and looking forward to
watching the season um
so i don't know if that's that's not
necessarily the
the like an ending theme or anything but
um but just sort of a relatability
that people can register with if that
makes sense and then i agree aaron with
what you said about
finding happiness at the end and maybe
fighting for what's important to you i
think there's a lot of that this season
i love it kevin anything to add
um i don't know you know like any good
show
there there's some things that end on a
final note in season eight but there's a
lot of things that are left open
um clearly one of these teams has got an
open story of what's gonna happen to
this person next
um so there's lots of story to be told
if we go into season nine
um both love stories and and just
characters in the town so
figures crossed we get to we get to tell
more stories yes
all toes crossed uh before we get into a
game that i want to play i just want to
ask about uh a funny moment
that occurred last year kevin and chris
you guys went on somewhat of like a cast
fishing trip which looked like a whole
lot of fun
and kevin you very famously wore your
team lucas shirt
for the occasion well i needed something
to get fish guts on it was the only
shirt that i was willing to
the truth the truth comes out everyone's
like oh it's so sweet oh it's
supporting lucas what's the worst shirt
i have
wow i did not think of it from that
perspective i truly thought that it was
kevin i thought it was you showing your
support for team lucas
of course it was team lucas
objectively as kevin as chris not as
your characters
if you were friends with elizabeth in
real life and she came to you and said
i've got this dilemma i've got these two
wonderful guys
what advice would you give her who would
you tell her that she should choose i've
said it
from day one drop the guys and go with
team hickam
day one you've got this eligible
bachelor just roaming around
great sense of humor
[Laughter]
a great guy but he has not put in the
work that
that nathan and lucas have so
is there is there advice that you would
give your good old pal elizabeth as
she's kind of
narrowing down and making her final
decision
yeah it's a it's a really tough yeah
place to be i'm
sorry girl well i'd say which
which one makes which one makes you the
happiest i don't know which one i think
it's tough i don't i don't know what to
say i mean
flip a couple i feel like there are two
great choices
maybe maybe put um
ally and baby jack in a room and see if
they get along
well for an extended period of time oh
that's a litmus test that's interesting
see if the sibling thing can work out
and if not head over to the saloon and
grab a pint okay okay
i won't push you guys any further on
that thank you for being so wonderful
and answering all those questions and
before we wrap
up i just want to ask you guys if you
have a message that you want to send the
hearties people all over the world who
have either been invested in the show
for years or perhaps over the last year
they found it
while they were at home and you know
brought them joy and comfort is there
any message that you want to send your
loyal fans
erin let's start with you i i would just
say um it is so gratifying to see
uh how our show has resonated with
people over the years
um and and i'm glad to hear that it's
brought a lot of people comfort
during this the crazy 2020 that we had
um and i'm just very very grateful you
know it's
it is a unique situation very unique to
be a part of a show that has the kind of
longevity that one calls the heart has
and as actors you know
job security is kind of a funny thing so
we are we're very lucky to be a part of
a show
that has kept us employed for this many
years
um because i think certainly for the
three of us acting is something that
isn't just a job it's something that is
very meaningful to us
brings us a lot of joy and so getting to
do
the thing that we love every day is
truly dependent on
the hearties because they're the ones
who are tuning in and keeping us on the
air
so i guess long story short i would just
say
i would just say thank you so much to
the hearties because without them we
wouldn't get to do what we love every
day
kevin do you want to add on to that yeah
i mean i mean
aaron said it's a great it's it's it's
cliche to be like you know if it wasn't
for you we wouldn't be here and
but but it's true and you know i do i
think like especially for chris and i
kind of coming on this is our third
season we've you know joined the show
with three years
i i think you know it is we should say
thank you for
to the hardys for kind of welcoming us
and then being there with us
whether what team you're on or whatever
it is but just
thank you for like letting us be part of
this world and kind of accepting us
and i'm i'm happy that we were able to
give you a storyline
that you guys were able to you know
continue on with the show after you know
the big changes that happened
i'm it's so nice to join something
and allow these new stories and and a
new voice to kind of come through hope
valley and um
thank you for kind of accepting it and
giving us your support
yeah chris
i would just want i agree with
everything that's been said and i'll add
on that i
want to say thank you and i'm very
appreciative that the hardys
fan bases i would say 99.9
positive in terms of feedback reactions
um you know i have friends who work on
other shows and it's
i mean some of them go through a real
tough time because the amount of
negative opinions and whatnot that they
get on their social media
it affects them but people think maybe
not because there's kind of this
this barrier this technical technology
is in the way and you're
separated but um but we see the things
that are
written and that are put out there and
everything
is always just so happy and positive
coming from the hardy so
thank you for being such a warm loving
fan base and thanks for keeping our show
going
and thanks for like kevin said allowing
kevin and i
into this world and being so accepting
of us
and looking forward to the next season
you two were hand selected with great
care
and we couldn't have made a better
decision and welcoming both of you
to one calls um i think i think
that you have made our show even better
and um and i also just
really love and care about both of you
personally and i'm grateful to have you
in my life
i love that you guys keep up with what
the fans are doing and talking about and
saying i mean do you see all the
time and love that they put into these
edits and these photos and
and the gifs yeah i've seen that i love
the gifts the games are my favorite
men too i do i've seen a lot of like um
the the
the videos to music in the last one some
of them are like very emotional
one of them i thought was real i was
like i didn't know they got the rights
to that song or hallmark
oh it was a family but it fit perfectly
it was amazing yeah they're great
yeah i love that all right before we
wrap up i want to play a very quick
rapid-fire game with you three i have
appropriately titled it
ready to date season eight um of course
elizabeth is
becoming more and more comfortable with
the idea of dating this season
i wanted to get your feedback on popular
common date activities okay so just
blurt out whatever comes to mind
whatever feels right in your heart
so first question movie on the couch
or movie in the theater couch couch
during a pandemic or no i would say
efficient like pie in the sky fish your
wish
all right all right couch couch
homebodies
i just i actually am not a big fan of
movies it's a date because you want to
talk to the person get to know the
person i don't want to sit next to them
and watch a third thing
you know what i mean i don't mind it i
mean
talk about though once once you leave
right i
i i picked the couch as well don't get
me wrong i mean
it's easier to communicate on a couch
though yeah the theater everyone's gonna
quiet i like going to theater i like
going to the theater and i think
i think you know you sit you watch the
movie and then you leave and it gives
you something to talk about for an hour
maybe you you know you realize you've
got something calm with this person or
you don't i don't know
anyways i said couch though it's so
funny anyway that's okay
in the last year all of our mindset goes
directly to couch
i'm excited to get back to the movie
theaters when it is deemed safe
um dress to impress or keep it casual
keep it casual oh i was gonna say dress
to impress
can i ask how far along in the dating
process are we for these questions is
this like a first date
or are we talking about like two or
three years in i think i think a first
date just kind of you know
getting to know someone elizabeth is
kind of just warm even though she knows
these guys she's really kind of just
warming up to the idea of
is this about a little bit no no no this
is just
it's just in honor of elizabeth it's
it's of course
it's just elizabeth and whitney is the
common theme that kind of blends it all
together
dress to impress kevin dressed to
impress aaron yes
i just can't get past the like sweatpant
thing
it's like this and and sweatpant with a
hole in it because it's all i wear now
so
snow or sand
uh i would go sand eventually like i
like yeah i would go sand over
eventually i like the snow i think
there's great stuff you can do in the
winter but i would i would prefer
the sand i might be snow yeah
are you a scared billboarder yeah
snowboard
i ski too actually but i have it in a
few years i might get some skis this
year
i might get back into it but currently
snowboarding
love it uh go out for a meal or make a
meal at home
go out for a meal go out for a meal
chris you want to grow okay no
i thought you were definitely going to
say make a meal at home you got all the
ingredients in your backyard
well i i love making meals at home but
i'm going back to the
the parameters of this is the first date
yes
okay let's go to a restaurant dress up
not go to the movie theater
come back and watch a movie on the couch
after and then you love it
um go to a concert or go out and do
karaoke
concert i think concert not singing yeah
i would you guys can sing i'm getting as
far away from that microphone as karaoke
when we went to that thing in denver
yeah you were fantastic i felt like i
was at a concert oh yeah
can you share what you perform yeah i
have videos remember
you want to see it don't do that
oh we definitely kevin was the guy that
he starts saying the karaoke bar and
everyone turns around and it's like
huh yeah they're like is that dell
really oh you know what it was it was um
lionel richie's
hello yes yes
yeah and which would you would you be so
kind as to give us a line right now
do you
[Music]
you can send it to me and we'll include
it in post because i think the artist
would love to see
i really i can't i really can't because
it's uh other like
if i send you that video of kevin
singing lionel
you're gonna die in denver who knows
what he'll then send you with me
like we did exactly start down this path
what a great video
kevin's singing lionel richie in a dive
bar in denver
that's so great okay so just to regroup
what did we vote everybody voted for a
concert
well i did i did yeah
yeah yes i would vote concert
can you can you throw out an artist
i really love gabe dixon band that's a
fave
okay dixon chris
oh man um
i i would go see anything at this point
please um
i yeah i don't know
you don't need to go anywhere though
chris because you've got such an
incredible record collection like what's
your go through
i'm staring at them right now and i'm
like who would i who would i want to go
see a lot of them are dead
you know who i've been listening to a
lot
on um just done like the on spotify is
um
who sings dale um from uh
oh um kevin
what's that how does it go
yes i've been listening to a lot of
harry belafonte lately
love it the classic great yeah pretty
great okay and my last one
uh split a bottle of wine or split a
dessert
bottle of wine that's the same thing
isn't it
well it's not dessert wine not ice wine
but
i want both i don't know one yeah
have your cake and eat it too okay aaron
wine
dessert i think sweet tea yeah
like a
chocolate cake or or
chocolate brownie you know when they
okay
when they bring out like warm gooey
chocolate chip cookies at the end of the
meal
yes in a skillet
oh my goodness you're really elevating
things a little mint sprig
let's do it let's do it kevin
not wine i'll do the wine you keep your
ice cream
yeah love it i appreciate you guys
playing along before we wrap up
aaron do you want to invite the hearties
and let them know when they can catch
the season eight premiere of one calls
the heart
sure hearties make sure you watch the
season eight premiere of when calls the
heart
only on hallmark channel the heart of tv
on sunday
february 21st at 9 pm 8 central
i cannot wait congratulations on yet
another amazing season
fingers crossed for season nine you guys
thank you bye bye
you